[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to this crash course on robotic
process automation
aka rpa before we begin
let me walk you through the content it's
going to cover
first we'll look at a quick introduction
to rpa
then i'll help you understand the top
reasons to learn rpa
moving on we'll work hands-on with the
help of two tutorials on uipath
followed by which we look at a detailed
comparison between
blue prism uipath and automation
anywhere
i will also guide you through the
correct path you could take to become an
rpa developer
and brief you about salary and skills
and lastly we look at the top
interview questions that will help you
crack your next rpa interview
and all of this under two hours so
without further ado
let's begin but before that if you wish
to keep yourself
updated with all the cutting edge
technologies then subscribe to our
channel and hit the bell icon
this is jim he is an accountant in a
multinational company
he handles several invoices and other
financial records like monetary
transactions
liabilities checks and ledgers on a
daily basis
one of his tasks is to copy all the
relevant information from these invoices
such as the name of the company invoice
id and data processing into a
spreadsheet
and mail the sheet along with other
financial reports to his superiors by
the end of the day
as any prompt employee he transfers all
the information to the sheet
attaches the reports and sends them over
to his boss via email every day
but over a period he starts finding this
task to be time consuming
and repetitive frustrated jim looks for
a way to reduce the time
and effort it takes to complete the task
and voila
he stumbles across robotic process
automation aka
rpa using robotic process automation he
builds a simple bot that extracts
information from
several invoices into an excel sheet
attaches all the necessary financial
reports
and sends them over to his superiors via
email at a specific time
every day so what exactly is robotic
process automation
robotic process automation rpa is the
use of software with artificial
intelligence and machine learning
capabilities to handle high-volume
repetitive tasks
that previously required humans to
perform some of these tasks include
addressing queries
making calculations maintenance of
records and performing transactions
there are several misconceptions about
rpa
rpa is not a humanoid robot it does not
have a physical form
and no resemblance to humans rpa cannot
replace humans or replicate human
cognitive functions it does not have a
brain of its own
and cannot perform logical or critical
thinking as humans do
the working of rpa includes four crucial
phases
one the planning phase typically
involves gathering the processes to be
automated
identifying the test objects and
finalizing the implementation approach
two the development phase includes the
creation of automation workflows
as per the agreed plan three deployment
and testing is a vital phase
since it uncovers any unexpected outages
and ensures a bug-free product
four lastly there's the support and
maintenance phase
which ensures that the product is
continuously updated with
smooth deployment across the user base
to meet the objectives of rpa
tools are used these rpa tools are
software applications that can configure
tasks
and automate them some of the popular
rpa tools in the market
are uipath automation anywhere blue
prism
workfusion pega and redwood among others
when it comes to quality rpa ensures
consistent
error-free output leading to reduced
operational risks
this in turn improves customer
satisfaction in the area of delivery
rpa can help decrease the average
handling time and this enhances the
customer experience
and ensures 24 7 business continuity
with respect to cost according to nascom
domestic businesses can reduce the cost
by up to 65
through rpa it offers a higher roi by
driving positive returns within quarters
as opposed to years other advantages of
rpa
include reduced training costs minimal
utilization of it resources
and easier software migration today
many domains and industries like banking
and finance i.t integration processes
human resources insurance agencies
marketing and sales
and customer relationship management
readily deploy rpa
rpa service adoption has been showing
tremendous growth
since 2016 and will continue to increase
beyond 2020.
according to mckinsey's research
knowledge and work automation could have
an economic impact
of five to seven trillion dollars by the
year 2025
it will impact more than 230 million
knowledge workers
which constitute nine percent of the
global workforce
any company which is labor intensive
where people are performing high volume
high transaction functions stand to
benefit the most with rpa adoption
boosting their capabilities and saving
money and time
now in today's video we're going to be
learning all about robotic process
automation so if you're new to this
topic then this session will definitely
help you understand rpa better so
without further ado
let's jump in and look at what's in
store for us so the topics we're going
to be covering in this session
are why rpa automation versus rpa
what is rpa what is not rpa features
benefits types some of our pa software
tools
its services some of the industries
adopting rpa
and its growth projections so let's
begin by understanding the necessity of
rpa
now imagine having to solve complex
mathematical problems manually
it's possible but not all that easy to
make life a little easier calculators
were invented
they proved to be accurate easy and time
saving however these conventional
calculators need human input
now this is partial automation so does a
calculator qualify to fall under the rpa
framework
well no robotic process automation on
the other hand would be completely
automating the working of a calculator
where it requires zero human interaction
now let's compare traditional automation
with rpa consider an invoice processing
software now this software would
automatically generate these invoices in
a strategic manner
however the processing requires human
interaction on the other hand to ensure
complete end-to-end automation
rpa plays the key role rpa is an
approach that allows
one to automate the manual interactions
in a known process
traditional automation involves
programming apis and integration tools
to integrate different systems
rp on the other hand mimics the actions
of a user at the user interface level
these actions could be mouse clicks or
keystrokes since the developer directly
interacts with the software
he must have a clear understanding of
the target system in case of automation
but that's not the case in rpa as long
as the bot can exactly follow the steps
the developer need not worry about the
underlying complexities
so let's move ahead and understand what
is rpa rpa is the use of software with
ai
and machine learning capabilities now
these softwares
handle high volume repeated tasks that
previously
required humans to perform now rpa
approach sticks to the front end
only making it easier for its users so
rpa basically is a configuration
that automates repetitive tasks some of
these tasks could be answering queries
making calculations maintaining records
or even handling transactions
to give you an example consider an
employee handling invoices in a company
now his duty would include printing
these invoices for audit purposes
now doing this regularly proves to be
strenuous and monotonous
rpa helps overcome this it can be used
to open the invoice mail from the
supplier
extract the invoice and print it for
records all of which requires zero
effort from the employee now i'm sure
you'll understand rpa better with a
small demonstration
now consider you have to display a
welcome message on a regular basis
now instead of manually typing it every
time you definitely want to automate it
for this purpose we make use of an rpa
tool
called ui paths now don't worry we'll
learn about this later in the session
ui path studio is a tool used to develop
rpa bots for specific functions
now let me navigate to my ui path studio
and here
i'll create a new project let me call it
message 101 and i'll say create
all right so this is how the ui path
studio looks let me get rid of this
and here you have various activities
that you can perform
so a sequence is basically a set of
activities that is defined
in a particular order it also executes
in that particular order so what i can
do
is i can drag and drop this here and
within the sequence
i drag and drop my activity so i want to
display a message
so i drag the message box and drop it
here the message that i want to display
must be quoted within double quotes so i
say
hello welcome to rpa
tutorial and i save it and after that i
run it so once i do that it has to
display the message
on my screen so let's see if it does
that voila here we go
you can see the message being displayed
so this was a simple example of how rpa
works
using this tool you can practically
automate complex functionalities
we learn all about ui path in detail in
the upcoming videos so stay tuned for
that
moving ahead let's see some of the
common misconceptions about
rpa rpa is not a humanoid robot
certain dynamic applications and
processes that require human
actions cannot be completely automated
rpa can also
not replace humans it can only be used
for known processes
it doesn't have a brain of its own and
cannot perform human-like activities
and lastly it cannot replicate human
cognitive functions
it definitely lacks logical thinking and
does not possess
decision making skills let's look at
some of the key features of rpa
a rich analytical suite now most
enterprise level rpa monitors
and manages automated functions from a
central console now this console can be
accessed from anywhere and offers basic
metrics
on robots servers workflows etc now this
solution of rpa requires no integration
since everything is inbuilt creation of
bots now rpa
tools allow quick creation of bots by
capturing mouse clicks and keystrokes
with built-in screen recorder components
now many
rpa products include the option to
create and edit bots
manually with the help of a task editor
scriptless automation
now rpa tools are code free and can
automate applications in any department
employees with less programming skills
can create bots through gui's or
graphical user interface
now this feature reduces the amount of
hand code writing and improves the rate
of delivery next up we have security
rpa tools enable the configuration as
well as customization of encryption
methods now this helps defend against
any interruption in the network
hosting and deployment rba systems can
automatically deploy bots
in groups of hundreds hence rpa bots can
be installed on desktops and deployed on
servers
to access data for repetitive tasks
lastly we have debugging
some rpa tools require to stop running
to rectify the errors while other tools
allow dynamic interaction
while debugging now this dynamic
approach allows to develop on the go
and to resolve issues in a runtime
environment without changing the process
now let's look at some of the benefits
of rpa reduces cost one of the most
important advantages of rpa is the quick
reduction in cost
by automating tasks the cost saving of
almost 30 percent can be achieved
software robots also cost
way less than a full-time employee
reduces operational risk
various companies generally prefer to
outsource busy work to external parties
now this comes with an inherent risk of
human errors and inefficiency
rpa brings forth a better solution and
since the work stays in-house there is
less operational risk
quality and accuracy rpa offers services
to processes
with high probability of human errors
thereby increasing accuracy robots are
reliable and consistent and don't
complain when expected to work
tirelessly
scalability with the help of rpa
companies can make adjustments
based on seasonality and can easily
scale up or down operations as needed
moving on let's learn about the types of
rpa first up we have unattended or
autonomous rpa now these are ideally
used for reducing work like completing
data processing tasks in the background
now these bots can be generally launched
at specific intervals
or they can be bought initiated or they
can be initiated when there's a data
input
second up we have attended rpa now these
bots live on the user's machines
and are triggered by the user so some
sort of human interaction is required
they're usually launched when they're
embedded on the employee's device
or they can be ordered and based on
conditions or they can be initiated with
the help of an rpa client tool
thirdly we have hybrid rpa as the name
suggests it's a combination of attended
and unattended rpa
these bots address front and back office
tasks in the enterprise
next up we have rpa software tools now
robotic process tools are used for the
automation of repetitive back office
processes now there are numerous rpa
tools available in the market
some of them are automation anywhere
uipath blue prism
pega and work fusion among others in the
upcoming videos we'll discuss some of
these tools in detail watch out for that
moving on let's look at some of the rpa
services now these rpa services
generally include common business
processes like opening emails and
attachments
filling in forms and moving folders
follow if then rules
connect to system apis extract
structured data from documents
make complex calculations monitor manual
processes and learn how to perform them
example machine learning copy and paste
read and write to databases
scrap data from documents login to web
or enterprise applications
and so on now that we have a clear idea
on what rpa is
let's go ahead and look at some of the
industries adopting rpa
first up we have banking and finance rpa
has been a boon to the finance industry
with its significant
impact on reducing considerable work
volumes human resources
typically with hr processes witnessing a
high volume of repetitive tasks
the rpa could significantly improve the
rate efficiency and cost effectiveness
in the functions
it can be used to run tasks in careers
and learning talent acquisition etc
marketing and sales rpa is helping
organizations in building the sales
pipeline and
engaging with their customers more
efficiently i.t integration processes
rpa can be used to integrate legacy and
newer systems in automation endeavors
insurance agencies rpa helps empowered
insurers in building a high growth
responsive business while optimizing
cost
lastly we have customer relationship
management rpa software can
automatically keep your crm maintained
with the most up-to-date and accurate
information
lastly let's look at the rpa growth
projections and its
future both rpa software and services
increased by huge amounts between 2016
and 2021
and beyond according to mckinsey
research knowledge and work automation
could have an economic
impact of five to seven trillion dollars
by the year 2025.
it will touch more than 230 million
knowledge workers which is almost nine
percent of the global workforce
any company which is labor intensive
where people are performing high volume
high transaction functions will boost
their capabilities and save money and
time with rpa
so why is rpa gaining popularity so
rapidly
and why do companies and techies have
rpa perspectives
so here are the 10 reasons why one
should learn rpa
so number 10 fast implementation
now getting data entry bots up and
running
goes quickly implementing a new rpa
software system
certainly happens much faster than
training a new person
you can have these data entry bots up
and running in just
days in contrast if you wanted to hire a
new
human employee you'd be taking a lot of
time in sorting out resumes conducting
interviews
going through the entire boring hiring
process and then finally when you find
the right person
you'd have to spend time and energy on
training them
however in case of rpa all of this is
countered
and number nine we have no training time
so now this is an important one
if your process changes and the bots
need to learn something new
you can either replace them with new
bots or alter their programming
now that again goes much faster than
training employees for new tasks
in terms of costs training an employee
for a new task will pan out to be
way more expensive and time consuming
next up the bots will never quit now
with rpa
you don't have to worry about employees
quitting or dealing with the turnover
bots don't care how hard they're working
or how boring their job is
or how repeatedly they're doing the same
tasks
again yes it would be ironic if the bots
got tired
software bots can work all the time 24
hours a day
every single day of the year at 100
capacity
now rpa doesn't take holidays it doesn't
have sick needs
and of course they do not have
unproductive days at all
well isn't that a treat to have someone
who never retires or decides it's time
to move to a different job
next up minimal i.t resources
maintaining software
bots requires minimal id resources in
some cases
it doesn't id doesn't need to get
involved at all
your rpa systems will be managed by the
software provider
they're responsible for maintenance and
updates all of that
it completely takes the burden off it
and saves your company a whole lot of
money
roi is visible now every organization
wants to quantify their gains many of
these organizations do not know how they
should determine their roi
but when it comes to adopting robotic
process automation
roi is visible it defines a clearer path
to demonstrate its
returns
complex problems can be solved now as
our data sources and analytical
capabilities have grown
so has the time required to build
various reports
robotic process automation system is
ideal for solution
to solve these types of problems the
system stores the information and it can
also remember
and transform this information very
easily
that means this makes you auditable and
tax ready
software migration now it's a fact that
software migrations are time consuming
and costly
migrating to a new software could take
months and cost
could turn out to be tens or thousands
of millions of dollars
what's even more frustrating is that at
all times
certain features and functionalities
which may have functioned in a
particular way in a previous
version may not even be present in the
updated version
so rpa helps with data migration with
accuracy speed and continuous updating
of software
rpa has a free tier many rpa vendors
offer free tiers some of these vendors
are blue prism automation anywhere ui
path among others
these rpa software vendors are offering
high
rpa software notably ui path with their
community edition
and workfusion with their rpa express
this helps lower the total cost of
ownership
there's no rip and replace now
rpa doesn't jeopardize an employee's job
but helps with the growth of new jobs
to do your work you need some additional
software yes
and virtual machines to deploy fully
independent digital bots
but you may not need to rip and replace
your existing infrastructures
also there's a common misconception that
rpa could steal our jobs
well that's not true monitoring and
controlling these bots are completely
the responsibilities of the developer
as a result rpa does not pull down your
existing systems
but it leverages them
lastly popularity and high salary
according to glassdoor the average
salary of an rpa developer in the us
is 77 000 us dollars and in india
the beginning salary for an rpa
developer is around 4.65 lakhs per annum
top tier companies like dell ibm
accenture
capgemini cognizant among others are
readily hiring rpa developers
now this is all you need to know about
why one should learn rpa
but if you're looking to become a
developer let's look at some of the job
roles and responsibilities
rpa developers are responsible for the
creation design
development and implementation of rpa
systems
an rpa developer is expected to provide
guidance with process design
design develop test automation flip
workflows
deploy rpa components be it bots robots
or development tools
support the implementation of rpa
solutions
create process documentation and also
assure the quality of the automation
now that we have a clear understanding
of what rpa is
and what it's not you must be wondering
how it works
so let's have a closer look at its
working
the first step towards any approach is
planning
in this stage the processes to be
automated are defined
which includes identifying the test
objects finalizing an implementation
approach
and defining a clear roadmap for the rpa
implementation
next we have design and development as
the name suggests
in this phase you start developing the
automation workflows
as per the agreed plan third is
deployment and testing
this phase typically includes the
execution of the bots
now any expected outages are to be taken
care of during the deployment
to ensure accurate functioning testing
of these bots for bugs and errors is
crucial
lastly is support and maintenance now
providing constant support helps in
identifying and rectifying the errors
better
moving on we have rpa software tools now
these tools typically help develop
and execute bots some of the rpa tools
are uipath
blue prism automation anywhere work
fusion among others
in this tutorial we will execute a bot
using the uipath tool
before executing a demo test case let's
go ahead and understand what ui path is
and its interface
uipath is basically an advanced rpa tool
which allows you to create control and
execute front office and back office
bots
with the help of visual templates and
diagrams now it also provides end-to-end
automation calling it hyper automation
uipath offers three different product
suites
first up we have ui path studio now it
is a platform to create automation bots
it encompasses hundreds of activity
templates and ready made components to
drag and drop now some of its features
include gui dashboard which basically
consists of activities like
send email display message and so on it
offers different types of recorders
to record user actions on multiple
platforms it provides logging and
exceptional handling
it also has reusable components now the
user can create these reusable
components to publish them together as
libraries
the next product suite is uipath robot
now they run automation bots that are
created using uipath studio
there are different types of robots
firstly we have the attended robots
now these robots work with you to speed
up the service desk and the help desk
it's basically used in activities where
human involvement is key
next up we have unattended robots now
they operate without the human touch
maximizing the cost and performance
benefits
for any variety of back office tasks the
third product suite is the orchestrator
now it is a centralized robot management
dashboard where you can easily deploy
secure and manage your ui path robots at
scale now here's the course of action
the first step is that the user creates
a bot
next the user has to save this project
and which is later used as a process
now once the process is created it is
assigned to a specific robot to execute
it
this collectively constitutes a job and
all of which is taken care of
by the uipath orchestrator now let's
understand the uipath interface in brief
first up we have the recorder now as the
name suggests
this component allows the user to record
all user actions
such as navigations clicks etc next up
is scraping now it involves two
components one is the screen scraping
which is the programmatic collection of
visual data and the other one is data
scraping which is the extraction of
structured data from an application
user events now all mouse clicks and key
strokes given by the user as input are
recorded using this feature
lastly we have variables now variables
are used primarily for using certain
features
now these variables hold different types
of data and can change over time
all right now that we have a fair
understanding of ui path
let's go ahead and execute a simple test
case so here's what we're going to be
doing
first we extract information about books
on the website that is goodreads.com so
what information are we extracting
so we're going to be extracting the
names and the authors of the new
released books
then this information is going to be
stored in an excel sheet
and this excel sheet is going to be sent
over an email
so let's go ahead and execute the test
case all right so let's go ahead and
open ui path studio
and here you go and click on new process
in the top right corner
all right and provide a name for it say
rpa
and i say create so now this is going to
create a workspace for you this might
take up a few seconds
and this is what the typical uipath
studio interface looks like
so moving ahead we need to create a
sequence of activities
so for that let's go ahead and say new
sequence to the top left corner
and provide a name for it i choose to
keep it sequence
so i say create but what exactly is a
sequence
now sequence is a set of activities so
all the activities mentioned in a
sequence
are executed in the same order all right
so now in our
use case we are going to be scraping
data from
the goodreads.com website right okay so
now we'll have to navigate to the
goodreads.com
website and i've opened it in my browser
so here we navigated to the most popular
books published in march 2020.
so now i have to extract data from this
right i need
two fields basically i need the name
of the book and the author all right so
what we're going to do is we go back to
uipath studio
and click on data scraping so go ahead
and click on data scraping
and here it says open your browser or
application
and wherever you want to extract your
data from and then we click on next
and then click on the field that you
want to select so i say
next and here i want just the name right
so i click on the name and it says you
selected an entire table cell would you
like to extract the data from the whole
table no
i just want the name of the table right
so i say no
and now the next thing you need to do is
you have to create a pattern
the tool needs to understand what
exactly you are
extracting so what we do is we have to
create a pattern
to do that we have to select a second
element so i say next again
and i click on the second name here i
say click
and now the name of the column that i
want to give
so i say books and i say next
now so this is how it's going to look
this is the data preview
right so next we need the name of the
author so i say extract correlated data
here
so go ahead and click on that and now i
need the name so i say
i click on sarah j maas and again to
create a pattern i need to select
another element
so i say next and click on the next name
of the author so i click on this
and i give the name author
for this column all right so i click on
next
okay so this is how it's going to look
so after this i say
finish all right so now it's going to
ask me if data is spanning across
multiple pages
now in our case if you look at this page
data is not spanning across multiple
pages say suppose you had one two three
four five saying there are more books
ahead then that would be data spanning
across multiple pages
so that is not the case here so i say no
in our case
and that is it so we have scraped our
data from
the website okay so now that we're done
with data scraping
the information that has been extracted
has to be saved in a csv file
so for that you have to create the file
so go to your
activities and say write
csv all right so just drag and drop
the activity here now it asks for two
fields
right so the first one is a target field
where the information is stored
so provide a name for it for that let's
go ahead and browse it
and in my case
i create a document say demo
one underscore rpa
and save it all right and the next field
is the write from field
now the information that you're storing
in the csv file
is basically the output of data scraping
so that is all the information from the
data scripting event is stored in an
output variable
so click on that and here you see you
have an output variable
so copy the output variable control c
and then paste it here
order now save the file and now let's
execute it to see if it successfully
works
so go ahead and click on play
so all right it's completed the
execution so let's go ahead and
check if it has completed the execution
correctly so
i go back to my documents ui path and we
have demo one
underscore rpa open that
and here we go we have the
name of the author and the book all
right so this works completely fine
okay so the next step in our use case is
to attach the csv file and send over an
email
now for that you have to provide your
credentials that is your email id and
the password
now these credentials are also used
multiple times across the test case
so instead of specifying it every time
we can create two variables
right one for the email id and one for
the password so for that click on
variables here
and say create variable and
okay we have one already here so let's
call it email
and the other one is called password
so go ahead and provide your credentials
so i provide my email id
and then my password
okay and then save it all right
now we have to attach this csv file and
send over an email
right for that we have an activity
called send smtp mail message so go
ahead and drag and drop it here
and now it has three fields it has the
two field the subject field and the body
field
right so two is where you provide the
email id
so here i just say email because i've
already defined a variable
the next is the subject so i say
attachment and say the body i'll keep it
simple and say pfa
okay now we have to attach the file
right so click on attach files
and here we have to provide the path to
the file
so go back to the place where you've
saved your
csv file and copy the path
and paste it here as an expression
and at the end you provide the name of
the file so it was demo one
underscore rpa dot csv
okay so now go ahead click on ok
now we have a lot of other fields to
provide here as well
so here we have
the port field now the smtp port that
we're using
is number 465 so go ahead and provide
that
and the server is basically
smtp.gmail.com
all right and again we have to provide
the email ids that is just
email and this is just password
and then two is also provided already
and the sender is again me
so i say email again and the password is
again
password all right
so now save it okay and as you can see
there are no errors that means it's good
to go
okay so let's go ahead and execute this
and see if it executes
successfully so go ahead and execute it
all right so it has successfully
finished its execution
so now let's go to my gmail account and
see
if i've received an email and yes i have
so go ahead and click on that and here
i download the file and see if it's
appropriately sent and here we go so
here we go we have the name
of the book and the author okay so with
this we've successfully
implemented an rpa bot for email
automation
hey everyone welcome to this session by
simply learn
in this video we will learn about ui
path studio in depth
and understand it's working with a demo
this tutorial
will help you understand the following
concepts you will learn what is ui path
and the various advantages of uipath
then
you will look at the different products
offered by uipath and understand the
uipath interface
after that you will see the companies
using uipath
and look at a demo to automate a task
using uipath studio
so without further ado let's begin
so what is ui path now rpa
is a technology with which human tasks
can be automated
to facilitate this a tool is required
uipath is one such tool among others
that are used to create bots with the
help of visual processes and diagrams
it provides complete end-to-end
automation calling it hyper automation
ui path was founded by daniel dynes and
marius turca
in 2005. uipath is specially used for
windows process automation
it automates repetitive tasks and lastly
uipath offers drag and drop
functionalities to make it easy to use
now since there are so many other tools
like blue prism automation anywhere in
the market
what makes ui path stand out so let's
look at the advantages of uipath
first uipath has an activity library
this library has several built-in
activities and features like display
message
input box and so on this improves the
customer experience
we will deal with these activities in
the demo later
next up is security rpa deals with a
variety of information like credit card
numbers
financial information and passwords
uipath
offers extensive security since all the
information can be encrypted and stored
on a centralized server
up next we have recorders so ui path
uses a micro recorder to record the user
actions such as mouse clicks and
keystrokes
once the actions are recorded they can
be emulated using emulators for quick
automation
third party integration ui path can be
integrated with third party plugins like
ibm watson and google plugins
then we have powerful debugging ui path
studio
comes with a debug component that helps
find and locate problems easily in
complex workflows
this is useful for viewing the execution
of each activity to verify what data it
gets
and if there are errors in producing
outputs
now let's understand the various ui path
products
first up is uipath studio this is the
platform to create the bots
this product consists of all the
necessary drag and drop activities
and a robust ui to help develop bots of
your choice
now the ui part studio consists of the
gui dashboard
it offers a visual dashboard with
activities like send email
display message and so on then we have
types of recorders
uipath studio offers various types of
recorders to record actions
on multiple platforms then we have
logging
and exception handling it offers various
options for debugging and exception
handling such as debug
open logs slow step etc and finally
we have reusable components the user can
create reusable components to publish
them together as libraries
next we have the uipath robots all the
automation tasks that created
are run by uipath robots there are two
types of robots
attended robots and unattended robots
attended robots
work with you to speed up service desk
and help desk it is used in activities
where human involvement is the key
unattended robots operate without human
touch maximizing cost and performance
benefits for any variety of back office
tasks
lastly we have the uipath orchestrator
the orchestrator is like a centralized
entity where you can deploy
secure manage all your automation tasks
here are the steps involved first
you create a bot now you create a
project and publish it as a process for
further use
once a process is created it is assigned
to a specific robot to execute
in an environment this collectively
constitutes a job
now let's move on to the architecture of
uipath
so on the top you have the client layer
consisting of uipath studio
and the uipath robot now the uipath
robot has two parts
one is the uipath agent service which
displays all the available jobs in the
system tree
and the other one is the uipath executor
service which is used to run the jobs in
one windows session
the server layer receives the robot once
it is ready for execution
with the help of the orchestrator you
can run the project on different pcs
the orchestrator monitors the deploys
configures
queue management and logging
lastly we have the persistent layer
which consists of the databases
it takes care of the queues and holds
information about the robot
configuration and the assigned processes
now that we know what ui path is let's
acquaint ourselves
with its user interface and understand
its components better
so this is what the typical interface
looks like
first we have the ribbon it consists of
three tabs
home design and debug home
is where you start a new project from
pre-defined templates or open a project
you recently worked on by default the
projects are created
in the location shown below next is the
design tab
design tab adds sequences flowcharts and
state machines to your project
it installs and manages activity
packages it builds interactions with ui
elements and then publishes your work to
orchestrator
finally is debug it debugs your workflow
while using debugging tools to set up
breakpoints monitor the execution of
activity step by step and adjust the
debugging speed
next on the screen is tools so the tools
tab can be used for installing
extensions from chrome
firefox edge java silverlight
citrix and windows remote desktop and is
also used for launching the ui explorer
and project dependencies mass update
tool
then we have settings the settings tab
has options for changing the interface
language
theme setting global preferences and
managing activity feeds
so you have general settings then there
is settings for design
locations managed resources and finally
license and profile up next
you have help the help tab directs you
to product documentation
release notes online resources the
community forum and the rpa academy
after that you have the recorder
the recorder component in uipath studio
allows the user to record ui mouse
movements
and keyboard activities to generate
automation scripts
after that you have scraping so
uipath studio supports two types of
scraping one is screen scraping and the
next one is data scraping
so screen scraping is programmatic
collection of visual data
and data scraping is the extraction of
structured data from an application
then you have user events user events
records events such as mouse clicks and
keystrokes
then you have variables so variables
hold different types of data
these variables can change over time
uipath makes an easy provision to create
and remove
unused variables on the bottom left
you have project so the project panel
enables you to view the components of
the current project add folders
open the file location manage
dependencies and adjust project settings
beside it you have activities panel
so the activities panel shows available
activities that can be added to the
current workflow
users can use the search box to find
activities navigate through them
using navigation keys and press
you also have the snippets panel which
enables you to easily reuse automation
it includes by default multiple samples
and snippets
to the bottom right you have the
properties panel which is contextual
and enables you to view and change the
properties of a selected activity
you also have the outline panel which
displays the project hierarchy
all available variables and nodes you
can highlight
activities in this panel by selecting
them in the designer panel
the output panel enables you to display
the output of the log message or write
line activities
among other things exceptions for
packages are also displayed in this
panel
so now that you have understood the
interface of uipath let's look at the
companies using uipath
so you have accenture capgemini
cognizant
ethos and deloitte to name a few
now we'll do a demo to automate a task
using uipath studio
so here is what we are going to do in
the demo we will create an automated
process to fetch data from a website
wherein the bot would extract data like
the name of the person
the phone number and the email id this
data will store it in an excel seat
and send it over an email now let's get
started
now to do this demo we'll be using the
fake name generator website to generate
random data of people and store this
data set in an excel sheet
now if i had to do this manually i would
first create an excel sheet
so let me open an excel workbook
i'll create a blank workbook
so this is where i'll put my data if i
had to do it manually
so now let me take you to the fake name
generator website
so i'll search for fakenamegenerator.com
so this is the website where you can
generate
fake names now
if i had to store this data in excel
i would manually copy paste each and
every detail
and paste it onto the excel sheet so for
that
first i had to create columns like name
then phone number
this in an email
after that i had to come back
to this and
copy each of these fields
so name
if i had to take the phone number
so i would copy this
and similarly for the email address as
well
for one record it is fine what if you
are asked to fetch 100 records or say
200 records
then this method is not at all feasible
it is time consuming and inefficient
you need to find a way where you can
automate this task
of fetching records uipath
is a solution for this so let's see how
we can automate this
task using the uipath studio
so i'll click on open main workflow
first we need to direct uipath to go to
the fake name generator website
for that we need the sequence activity
so let me search for sequence here so
under activities
i'll search for sequence
and i'll drag it
here
after that i need to open the website in
a web browser
so for that let me search for another
activity called open browser
so under activity i look for
open browser
so i'll drag it on the sequence itself
now it is asking you to insert the url
of the website
and it must be within double quotes
so i will go to my website
copy paste the url i have to give this
url within double quotes then i'll paste
it
now we need to select the name of the
browser where you want to open this
website
so under input and browser type
i'll choose chrome
now let me go ahead and run this file
so under debug
i have run file i'll click on it
so as you can see the website is
automatically opened in a new window on
chrome
i'll close this
the next step in the process is to tell
the program how many records we want to
fetch from the website
for this we will create an input dialog
box
so under activities
i'll search for input
so here you get the input dialog box
i'll drag and drop it on the top
now it is asking us to give the details
so i'll put it within double quotes say
enter the details of customers
or say people
and then here i'll give
enter the number of
records you want to fetch
now now i have to store this information
in a variable
so under variables
i'll create a variable and name it as
total
is the total number of records i want to
fetch
similarly under output result i will
give the same variable name as total
now we need to fetch the details a
number of times repeatedly
say for 10 times or 20 times or 50 times
to do this operation i'll be using a do
while loop
so to use a do while loop
i'll first search for do while
and i'll drop it to the do section of
the sequence
as you can see do-while has two
components
one is the body and the other one is
condition
the body has the things that you want
the program to do
the condition is where you evaluate
certain conditions every time when the
program has to do a task
so for every step or iteration it will
check if the condition is true
or not and go inside the body of the
loop
now for doing this we need to assign a
variable
so let's name the variable
as val
and i'll change the variable type to
integer
and i'll make the scope to sequence
i'll also assign a default value of 0.
now we'll compare this val to the
variable total
so the condition i'll give is check if
val is less than total
so under condition i'll give
val less than total so every time the
value of val
is less than the total it will keep
fetching the records from the website
you can see it has thrown some error
now this is because our total variable
is of type string
while the val variable is of type
integer
so you can't compare an integer
with a string variable so that would be
absurd
we need to convert the total variable to
an integer using the c and function
so here itself i'll write c int
which is convert this total variable to
integer
you can see the error is gone the next
thing i want to do is if the value of
the valve variable is less than total
i'll increment the value of val to 1.
so to do that i'll use an activity
called assign
so i'll check for assign
and i'll drag it onto the body
so here i'll give val
equals to val plus one
this will make sure the value of val
increases by 1
every time there is a new record
inserted it will continue until the
value of val
no longer matches the total
so the next job is to extract
information from the website
to do this we will use the get full text
activity
so i'll search for get full text here
and i'll drag it right below the assign
activity
now you need to select the information
which you want
so first i want to get the name i'll
click on the indicate element inside
browser
and then select the name of the person
so i'll click on this
and i click on the name
there you go now we need to store this
name in a variable
so i'll create a variable
so under variable i'll create
a variable called name
and in the output also
i'll give the same variable name
next i want to fetch the phone number of
the person
so i'll again select get full text
and i'll drag it
here
i'll click on indicate element inside
browser
so i'll scroll down and i'll select the
phone number of the person
so we have selected the phone number
similarly i'll store this phone number
in a variable
i'll create a variable called
phone underscore number
and the output text box also will
give the same variable as
phone underscore number
after that i want to get the email
address of the person
so i'll continue with the same drill
i'll select the activity once again
which is get full text
and i'll drag it right here i'll click
on indicate element inside browser
and now
we'll select the email address which is
this one
similarly i'll store the email address
in a variable called email underscore id
and in the output also we'll give the
same variable name which is email
underscore id
now we need to store the names phone
numbers and email ids into an excel
sheet
for that we need to create a data table
so i'll search for data table under
activities
let me go ahead and do that
so i'll
choose build data table and drag it
right below
the input dialog box
now this table has to be assigned to a
variable
so let me do that
let me give a variable name as
fetch underscore
data underscore table similarly
the output also will give the same
variable name which is
fetch underscore data underscore table
one thing i need to tell you here is we
change the variable type
so i'll select browse for types
and look for data table
which is system.data
i'll drill down and search for data
table which is this one
click ok
we need to assign the column names to
this data table
so let me now do that
i'll uncheck all this
and select the columns so you will give
the
first column name as name itself
click on ok select one more column
give it as phone number
click ok and then
we need the email address
i'll hit ok
so we are done
so first the data table is created and
then we'll write this data to an excel
file
after that we need to create rows for
the data table
for that i will search for row
under activities i'll search for row
and i'll select
add row i'll select add
data row
i'll place it right below where we have
created all the variables
now i want to add a row for the name
phone number and email address
so under input i'll select
array row i'll expand this
and within curly braces i'll give my
variable names
so those would be name
give a comma and then
phone underscore number
comma email
underscore id
click ok
i made a mistake it should be within
curly braces
okay now to tell the table to which it
should write the rows to we need to
assign
under the data table name so under data
table
i'll give fetch underscore data
underscore table
for every iteration a record will be
added to the table
then we need to refresh the page to
extract the next set of information
so for that i will add another activity
called click
and drop it right below the add data row
so under activities i'll search for
click and i'll select
mouse click and i'll drop it
right below this one
now we need to indicate where do we want
to click from the browser
so click on this
go on top and
select generate so we want to click on
generate
next i will write the data to a csv file
so i'll search for write csv under
activities
and i'll drop it towards the
end of the sequence right here
now you need to give the location where
you want to place this file on your
system
and give the source from where it will
take the information
so let's give the location where you
want to place this file
i'll place it on my desktop itself i'll
name
this as fetch
save it and
for the source i'll give
patch underscore data underscore table
we are all set now let's run it
so under debug file i'll select
run file
i'll enter the number of records
so let me fetch 10 records click on ok
now this might take some time
i believe it has run successfully now
let me check for my csv file
that should ideally be on my desktop
there you go so we have the csv file let
me open it
you can see it has extracted
10 rows of data and three columns
namely name of the person the phone
number and the email address
so we are done with the first task of
automatically generating data from a
website
the next task is to send this file over
email
now to send an email you need the smtp
activity
so under activities i'll search for
smtp
i'll drag it right below here
now we need to configure this
i'll be actually sending this email from
someone else's email id
to my email id so under 2
i'll give my email address which is
within quotes i'll type abhijit dot
biswalat simplylearn.net
i'll give a subject as
automatic
data extraction
under body i'll give something like hi
please find a test now
we have to attach the file
we have to give the location of the file
here so
let me go to properties
and i'll select this
cancel
paste this here followed by
the file name which is fetch
dot csv
i'll click on ok
after that
i have to give the host port number
which is 465
and the
and the server name
which is smtp
under log on i'll give the sender's
email id
i have to give the password as well
under the receiver it's my email id
which is rbg.bushwa
simplyloan.net for the sender i'll give
the email ids
in my dot this panda at simplylearn.net
and i'll give a dummy name my
so we are almost done let me now go to
debug file
and run this
it is asking to enter the number of
records i will give
5 click on ok
this will take some time so let's just
wait
so we have successfully run our program
now let me check my inbox if i have got
any mail from
chinmay so there you go
i've got this email and below you can
see
the fetch.csv file attached and it has
five rows
now assuming you have a basic
understanding of rpa
let's go on and compare the popularly
used tools
first up is trial version every tool
generally offers a trial version for its
users
to get acquainted with the tool this
helps the users understand the tool
better
and decide if they want to proceed with
using the tool
blue prism offers a free trial version
it's available in two options
either on the cloud or on the local
computer
uipath also offers a free edition both
trial and license versions are available
automation anywhere
offers a free community version and both
tried and licensed versions are
available
next up is base technologies base
technologies define the technology with
which the software was built
blue prism is based on c sharp uipath is
based on microsoft vendors
like sharepoint kibana and elastic
search
while automation anywhere is based on
modern java technologies
the third feature of comparison is
process designer
blue prism enables you to create design
edit as well as
test business processes from the visual
business object
now a vbo is like an adapter provided by
blue prism
for communicating with an application
each visual business object
implements a specific set of operations
on an application's user interface
so these are basically like objects that
encapsulate a particular functional
logic
uipath on the other hand acts as a
visual process designer
with developer friendly options now a
visual process designer is a dashboard
consisting of various tools through
which the developer can define the
automation tasks
automation anywhere is developer
friendly with a visual interface
built for business users along with
advanced features for developers
business users and developers can work
side by side to build bots
they can see the visual interface and
code in a single screen
the next feature of comparison is
accessibility
blue prism offers browser-based access
only
ui path and automation anywhere on the
contrary
offer both application based and
browser-based accessibility
in case of automation anywhere the
control room can be accessed
with a browser or a mobile application
this is the only platform
where users can create bots on any
device or any operating system
moving on to the next feature
learning now in case of blue prism the
user should have the necessary knowledge
of programming
he should be able to create business
objects and manage them in the control
center
ui path enables you to design automation
processes visually through diagrams
the developer need not know a
programming language in particular
when it comes to automation anywhere it
is developer friendly
and offers both visual and programming
features
business users can build bots with the
help of drag and drop features
beginners benefit from the built-in
product walkthrough
next up is robots now before we jump in
let's discuss what the different types
of bots are
there are two types of boards we have
the front office boards
whose deployment is in the user's
control
we also have back office bots that can
run on locked machines from an
orchestrator
the user may not be actively involved in
its working
so moving on to the comparison blue
prism offers back office automation only
ui path and automation anywhere offer
both front and back office automation
in case of automation anywhere the hbc
or the human bot collaboration feature
enables humans
and bots to work together to complete a
task and also to manage exceptions
and escalations
moving on the next feature is macro
recorder
now the macro recorder allows you to
record keyboard activities
and mouse events to generate automation
scripts
these activities are arranged based on
the order
or sequence of actions being performed
on the screen
so moving on to the comparison blue
prism does not use a macro recorder
uipath makes use of a mac2 recorder to
enable fast process mapping automation
anywhere
offers a universal recorder so that the
user need not select
different recorders for different tasks
moving on to the next feature
architecture
and an application that runs on the
client side and accesses the remote
server for information
uses a client server architecture
whereas an application that runs
entirely
on a web browser uses the web
architecture
in case of a client server architecture
the user interaction with the server
is always through a user interface or
application on the client side
on the other hand in a web application
the user interaction
is thoroughly through a web browser now
blue prism and uipath both
incorporate a client server architecture
automation anywhere incorporates a
cloud-native web-based microservices
architecture
it is the only platform that provides a
complete digital worker solution
on the web users with any skill level
can instantly start building robots on a
browser without any heavy installation
the next feature is accuracy blue prism
is accurate for desktop
web and citrix automation ui path
shines in citrix automation designed for
bpo automation
and automation anywhere shines in citrix
automation
with ai sense technology well
any automation solution built using a
virtual desktop
or built to work in virtual desktops is
called citrix automation
moving on to the next feature
reusability
blue prism consists of a library of
business objects
that can be reused across multiple
methods
it also offers high reliability
in the case of uipath the processes can
be used for various synthesis services
with several workflow modules as a
result
uipath offers a high degree of usability
and moderate reliability
in the case of automation anywhere apart
from the standard common library
users can develop custom actions upload
and manage packages in their enterprise
control room
every bot created in automation anywhere
is reusable
the bot store has hundreds of
pre-configured bots and digital workers
to kick start a user's rpa journey
next up is pricing blue prism has a high
cost of acquisition
it also offers restricted training
uipath offers effective pleasant entry
level pricing
automation anywhere offers attractive
entry-level pricing
its users also experience the lowest
total cost of ownership
because of its native capabilities and
web-based architecture
moving on to the last feature
certifications
blue prism offers several certifications
like blue prism professional developer
blue prism rom architect among others
uipath provides free online training
and certification programs like rpa
developer advanced certification
automation anywhere university offers
free online training
and certification programs for both
students and advanced practitioners
professionals can also avail job role
specific certifications
there are several rpa tools in the
market today however
blue prism automation anywhere and
uipath are leading the market
first let's understand who an rpa
developer
is now generally speaking
an rpa developer is someone who works
cross-functionally
with business operations and business
analysts
to create and optimize workflow
processes
now however this is a relatively new
career path and many organizations
formal titles for rpa developers differ
now other similar positions may use
titles like process designer or
automation architect
but no matter the title the role of a
successful rpa developer
requires specific skills and best
practices like documentation and
planning
now in order to automate a business
process an
rpa developer will be required to create
workflow diagrams
and strategically document the process
prior to implementation
now he may also be responsible for
testing and bug fixes
so coding skills are also important
now in order to become a successful rpa
developer
you must have the ability to navigate
through appropriate technologies
such as uipath or automation anywhere
however there are a few prerequisites to
become an rpa developer
well it's not very hard but a little
prep is necessary
so let's go through them one by one
first up is strategic planning now
planning is a critical
phase in any development life cycle the
rpa developer regardless of the
designation
should possess the aptitude to ensure
strategic planning
strategic planning basically includes
design
development and implementation of rpa
systems
this also helps streamline the entire
business
to optimize the efficiency
next up is analytical skills now again
as the name suggests
it's crucial to analyze the information
and make decisions
to maximize your efficiency right now
these are skills that one develops when
they're exposed to it
so over a period of time you're going to
develop these skills not to worry about
it now
next up is problem solving skills now
these skills are again crucial
to predict any potential outages and
equip the entire unit
to overcome any unforeseen interruptions
from the business perspective as well
problem solving skills play a
significant role in ensuring
smooth conduction of tasks
experience in programming languages like
say c plus plus
c python ruby java is also crucial
next up is hands-on experience on rpe
tools
and cognitive platforms like blue prism
automation anywhere
redwood openspan etc
now other general skills include
communication skills as well
now this is pivotal for any organization
now the developer should be outspoken
and should articulate new ideas
now that you're familiar with the skills
required let's look at the job
description for an rpa developer
and some of his responsibilities so
here's a screenshot of the job
advertisement
posted by ibm
as mentioned some of the
responsibilities include
crafting automation process solutions
coding and scripting in
any of the automation tools configuring
new automation using core automation
tools
communicating with business analysts and
clients building and documenting
test procedures supporting the
operational teams during
any rollout phases supporting existing
processes and implementing change
requirements
and successfully managing any sort of
issues so if you're aspiring to become
an rpa developer
then these are some of the job
responsibilities that you will have to
readily take up if you're still
wondering if this field has scope for
development in the coming years
let me clarify it for you so let's go
ahead and look at the rpa growth
projections and salary
according to gartner robotic process
automation software
grew up by 63 in 2018 making it the
fastest growing segment of the global
enterprise software market
now the growth curve has also been
steadily increasing since 2016
and continues beyond 2020. now it is
also predicted that rpa will touch more
than 230 million knowledge workers
which constitute up to say nine percent
of the global workforce
now any company which is labor intensive
where people are performing
high volume high transaction functions
can totally benefit from rpa
so if you're still skeptical about
picking up rta i hope this clarified it
for you
so moving on to salaries in the u.s the
average sanity of an rpa developer
is around 76 000 us dollars
the average site of an rpa developer in
india is around 6 lakh rupees per annum
so the companies that are already hiring
for rpa developers
are ibm capgemini emphasis
volvo and accenture among others
moving on here are a few tips to kick
start your rpa career
so let's go ahead and look at them one
by one
first up is to choose your rpa platforms
now all rpa tools have graphical user
interface
or guis but it's really helpful to
understand the underlying technology
now this comes in extremely handy when
the developer has to create
more complex c personalized or advanced
bots
so if you are a python developer then
you can start off by
working with argos labs so this allows
the developers to build plugins with
almost no effort from the existing
python code
so if you're a python developer then you
can start off by working
with argos labs now this really allows
developers to build plugins with
literally no effort
and if you're a dot net developer then
you can start off with uipath or
automation anywhere's community editions
so if you're a java developer then you
can start off with automation anywhere
and if you're a developer with no
experience then you can
begin with any of the leading rpa
providers
now tip number two is to start building
there are plenty of free materials and
guides to help you
begin your rpa journey so some of the
famous or well-known rpa tools are blue
prism
work fusion ui path automation anywhere
etc so just start working on them
tip number three is build your github
repository
no matter how small or simple you think
your project is
go ahead and put it on your github
repository this totally adds credibility
to your profile
even if you're attending interviews one
look at your github repository is going
to make them realize how
good of a developer you are
tip number four is to take up
freelancing projects
now again to start off you can take up
say non-paid or even low paid projects
some of the websites that you could look
up are upwork
freelancer troll answer people per hour
so tip number five is to start a blog
now having your own blog
will add credibility to your profile no
matter how less you've worked on any
projects
you can go ahead and type in all the
information you want
recruiters can also have a glance at
your profile you're definitely going to
get some extra points for this
tip number six is to ensure you update
your resume and profile
now keep your resume and profiles
updated on all job portals like linkedin
indeed simply hired and
so these were some simple tips to help
you become an rpa developer
now that we've established that rpa has
a steep growth curve
let's look at the rpa job roles that you
should look out for
we have the rpa developer senior rpa
developer
rpa process architect rpa developer
senior consultant
project manager lead developer business
analyst
and rpa data analyst
now these job roles come with specific
responsibilities depending on the
designation
however there are a few common
responsibilities of an rpa developer
let's go ahead and check them out
now the first one is strategic planning
skills now planning is a crucial phase
in any development life cycle
the rpa developer regardless of the
designation should possess the aptitude
to ensure strategic planning
planning includes the design development
and implementation of rpa systems
this also helps streamline the business
next up is strong analytical skills now
to understand the client's requirements
and cater to the needs accordingly
is crucial analytical skills are also
important to predict or identify
potential bugs and errors and rectify
them
now this scale is especially required if
you're involved in the overall
development
next we have strong problem solving
skills now this again is extremely
crucial to predict
any outages and equip the entire unit to
overcome any unforcing interruptions
from the business perspective as well
problem solving skills play a
significant role in ensuring smooth
conduction of tasks
experience in any programming language
such as c c
plus plus python ruby java or dot net
is also important hands-on experience in
rpa tools and cognitive platforms such
as blue prism
automation anywhere ui path open spam
etc is necessary communication skills
are pivotal for any organization
the developer should be outspoken and
articulate any new ideas
you should also be confident to raise
concerns and be as transparent as
possible
in the long run this only proves to be
helpful to the organization
lastly we have exposure to sql now
experience with database be it sql or
nosql is highly preferred
it's always an added advantage if you
have the knowledge about accessing and
managing databases
next up we have rpa developer salaries
now the salaries will differ depending
on the location your experience and also
the designation
now in the u.s here are the job salaries
and
the roles according to glassdoor an rpa
developer in the u.s
earns around 76 000 us dollars per year
the nrp developer senior consultant
earns around 99
000 us dollars per year an rpa process
architect
earns an average salary of 95 000 us
dollars
and a senior rpa developer earns an
average salary of 92 000 us dollars
an rpa project manager earns around 73
000 us dollars per annum
an rpa lead developer earns an average
salary of 99
000 us dollars per annum an rpa business
analyst earns around 68 000 us dollars
per annum
and the data analyst earns around 62 000
us dollars per annum
moving on to india the average salary of
an rpa developer is around 5 lakhs 98
000 rupees that of a senior consultant
a senior rpa developer and an rpa lead
developer is around 14 lakhs per annum
and the average salary of an rpa
business analyst is around 5 lakhs 40
000 rupees
now let me quickly run you through a
sample resume of an rpa developer
now this is just a template and you can
alter it according to your needs
first up is your general information
like name phone number and your email id
then you can give a quick description
about yourself and your strengths
you can also mention the objective as to
why you're applying and what you're
looking for in the organization
you can include your linkedin profile
link and your github link
one look at your linkedin profile is
enough for anybody to gather all the
information necessary
so make sure that it's updated moving on
you could mention your experience
now here you would have to mention the
names of your previous organizations
along with your designation
and the tenure you could also include
your key responsibilities in these
organizations
along with the responsibilities you
could also mention the awards that you
received in your organizations
next up is your educational background
you can mention the university that you
graduated from
and this require that you have a degree
in computer science
you can also go ahead and mention your
gpa
the next section is skills now this is
pretty crucial in the technical skills
section you could mention about
different rpa tools that you've worked
on if you're good at a particular
programming language
go ahead and mention that as well as
mentioned earlier
any experience in database management is
an added advantage
if you have any experience go ahead and
mention that moving on to non-technical
skills
you could mention any extracurricular
activities that you're proud of
some soft skills that you feel worth
mentioning can be added in this section
mentioning the languages that you know
can also boost your resume
now given all this it's fundamental that
you do not lie on your resume
in today's video we're going to discuss
the top rpa
interview questions now if you're
looking to make a career in this field
and if you're just browsing around for
jobs then you're in the right place
this video will absolutely help you
crack that next interview of yours
so without further ado let's begin
the first question is what is rpa
now robotic process automation is the
use of software
with artificial intelligence and machine
learning capabilities
to handle high volume repetitive tasks
that previously required humans to
perform
now some of these tasks could be
addressing queries
making calculations maintenance of
records or even performing transactions
now rpa is a form of automation that
basically sticks to the front end of the
system
and carries out tasks without having to
move to the back end
now this is an essential feature of rpa
next up is mention a few applications of
rpa
there are several applications to
mention a few we have open mails and
attachments
fill in forms and move files and folders
follow if then rules
connect to system apis extract
structured data from documents
make complex calculations monitor manual
processes and learn how to perform them
read and write databases scrape data
from documents
and even log into web enterprise
applications
next question is mention a few
advantages of rpa
firstly rpa reduces cost now by
automating tasks
the cost saving of almost 30 percent can
be achieved through rpa
rpa reduces operational risks various
companies prefer to outsource busy work
to external parties
now this comes with an inherent risk of
human errors and inefficiency
now rpa brings forth a better solution
and since work stays in-house there's
less
operational risk next up is quality and
accuracy
rpa offers services to processes with a
high probability of human errors thereby
increasing accuracy
robots are reliable and consistent and
don't complain when expected to work
tirelessly
next up is scalability with the help of
rpa
companies can make adjustments based on
seasonality and can easily scale up or
down the operation as needed
reduced workload automating tasks like
report making can significantly reduce
the workload on the employee allowing
them to focus on other critical tasks
improved customer satisfaction since
accuracy is maintained and operational
risk is minimal customers are provided
with quality content
lastly we have improved business results
since all employees are focusing on
activities that add more value to the
company
improved results in the business are
visible
the next question is what are some
industries that can benefit from rpa
there are several industries and domains
that are currently benefiting from rpa
to mention a few there's banking and
finance i.t integration processes
human resources insurance agencies
marketing and sales
and customer relationship management
moving on to next question what are rpa
tools
now to meet the objectives of rpa rpa
tools are used
they are the software with the help of
which one can configure tasks and build
bots to automate them
some of the popular ones in the market
today are ui path blue prism
automation anywhere work fusion and
redwood
moving on to next question explain the
working of rpa
now the typical working of rpa includes
four crucial stages
the first stage is planning in this
stage the processes to be automated are
defined which includes identifying the
test objects
finalizing the implementation approach
and defining a clear roadmap for the rpa
implementation
the next step is design and development
in this phase
you start developing the automation
workflows as per the agreed plan
thirdly we have deployment and testing
this phase typically includes the
execution of the bots
any unexpected outages are to be taken
care of during the deployment
to ensure accurate functioning testing
of these bots for bugs and errors is
crucial
lastly we have support and maintenance
providing constant support helps in
identifying and rectifying the errors
better
moving on to the next question what is
the difference between traditional
automation and
rpa
here's a simple image for you to go on
to talk about the differences
traditional automation involves
programming apis and integration tools
to integrate different systems
rp on the other hand mimics actions of a
user at the user interface level
in the case of traditional automation
the developer needs to have a good
understanding of the target system
while in rpa as long as the bot can
exactly follow the steps
the developer need not worry about the
underlying complexities
the next question is mention the types
of rpa
now basically there are three types of
rpa first up
is unattended or autonomous rpa now this
is
ideal for reducing work like completing
data processing tasks
in the background they do not require
any human intervention
now these bots can be launched at
specific intervals
or they could be bought initiated or
they could be triggered
by some data input next up is attended
rpa
now these bots live on the user's
machine and are triggered by the user
they can be launched when embedded on an
employee's
device or they can be autonomous based
on certain conditions
or they can be launched using the rpa
client tool
lastly we have hybrid rpa it has a
combination of
attended and autonomous bots now these
bots address
front and back office tasks in the
enterprise
the next question is what are front and
back office spots
now front office bots are those whose
deployment
is totally in the user's control they
require human intervention they work
from the same desktop as that of the
user
it can only be triggered by local
machines manually and cannot run
remotely
when it comes to back office bots these
bots can run on locked machines from the
orchestrator
the user may not be actively involved in
its working
and these bots can be triggered remotely
by servers
the next question is what are some
features of rpa
up is rich analytical suite now rpa
monitors
and manages automated functions from a
central console
now this console can be accessed from
anywhere and offer basic metrics on
robots
servers workflows and more simple
creation of pods
rta tools allow quick creation of bots
effortlessly by capturing mouse clicks
and keystrokes
with built-in screen recorder components
scriptless
automation rpa tools are code free and
can automate
any application in any department
employees with less programming skills
can create bots through guis
security rpa tools enable the
configuration as well as customization
of encryption capabilities
for securing certain data types to
defend against the interruption of
network communication
hosting and deployment rpa systems can
automatically
deploy bots in groups of hundreds hence
rpa can be installed on desktops
and deployed on servers to access data
for repetitive tasks
debugging some rpa tools required to
stop
running to rectify the errors while
other tools allow dynamic interaction
while debugging
this is one of the most powerful
features of rpa
moving on what are the major differences
between blue prism and uipath
moving on to the first feature is trial
version
blue prism offers a trial version it's
available in two options either on cloud
or on the local computer ui path on the
other hand
offers free addition both trial and
license versions are available
moving on to base technologies blue
prism is completely based on c-sharp
ui path is based on sharepoint kibana
and elasticsearch
moving on to process designer blueprism
allows you to create
design edit as well as test business
processes
from the visual business object but what
exactly is a vbo
a vbo can take the form of a set of
coded functions
which may be written in vb.net or
csharp.net
uipath acts as a visual process designer
with friendly
developer options now a visual process
designer basically is a dashboard
consisting of various tools
through which a developer can define the
automation tasks
moving on to accessibility blueprism
allows
only browser-based accessibility uipath
on the other hand provides mobile and
browser accessibility
moving on to robots blueprism offers
back-office automation only
while uipath offers both front and back
office automation
the next crucial factor is a macro
recorder
in case of blue prism a macro recorder
does not exist
while in the case of ui path it consists
of a macro recorder enabling faster
process mapping
moving on what is citrix automation
any automation solution built using a
virtual desktop or built to work in
virtual desktops
is citrix automation it plays a major
role
in small to corporate companies like bpo
and contact centers
where applications are being accessed
remotely because of security
considerations
next question is what is uipath studio
now uipath studio is basically a
platform to create the automation bots
it encompasses hundreds of activity
templates and
made components to drag and drop ui path
studio consists of
first up is gui dashboard it offers a
visual dashboard with activities like
send email display message and so on
it also consists of different types of
recorders uipath studio offers various
recorders to record actions on multiple
platforms
next up is logging and exception
handling it offers various options for
these two
such as debug open blog slow step etc
lastly it offers reusable components
here the user can create usable
components
to publish them together as libraries
moving on what are activities in uipath
the activities panel shows available
activities that can be added to the
current workflow
users can use the search box to find
various activities
navigate through them using navigation
keys and press
system activities pack contains all the
basic activities used for creating
automation projects
these activities enable the robots to
manipulate data tables by adding or
extracting information
or directly interact with directories
and files on your machine
performing any action a human user would
also there are other types of activities
in the pack
that aid in the creation and execution
of automation projects themselves
such as logical operators and
expressions
moving on what is a sequence in ui path
a sequence is a simple linear
representation that flows from top to
bottom
and defines which activities are to be
performed
all right you can see a simple example
on your screen here
so to give you a detailed explanation
let me just navigate to ui path
and here i can create a new sequence
i go to new click on sequence
and let me call it sequence as it is and
say create
all right now a sequence is created so i
want to display two messages
so let's look for the activity that is
message box
i drag and drop it here
and let me display hello first
and i drag another message box and after
that i drop it here and
okay let me do that again all right and
here
i display welcome all right
so let's save this and debug
according to the logic hello has to be
displayed first
and then welcome right so let's go ahead
and see if it does that
all right you see a hello message first
followed by which you can see the
welcome message
so this is what a sequence is
moving on to the next question what is
scraping in uipath
now scraping can be done in two ways
first up is data scraping
now this is a technique with the help of
which structured data can be extracted
from the web or any application and
saved to a database or a spreadsheet or
a dot csv file
in the case of screen scraping it is a
process of collecting screen display
data from one application
and translating it so that another
application can display it
now you can see the two options on the
top of your user interface in ui path
moving on what are uipath robots
now uipath's robots run the automation
that is created using the uipath studio
now there are two types of robots as
discussed earlier we have attended
robots
now they work with you to speed up the
process like service desk operation or
help desk operations
now it is used in activities where human
involvement is key
next up is unattended robots now these
operate without the human touch
maximizing cost and performance benefits
for any variety of back office tasks
next question what does a uipath
orchestrator do
now the orchestrator is a centralized
robot management dashboard
where you can easily deploy secure and
manage your ui path robots at scale
first you have to create the bot the
project
is then published as a process for
further use
once a process is created it is assigned
to a specific robot to execute an
environment this collectively
constitutes a job
all of this is taken care of by the
uipath orchestrator
next question how is exceptional
handling achieved in uipath
exception handling is one of the error
handling methods in uipath
the error handling activity has four
options
first up is read through now using this
activity a robot throws an exception
again which was previously caught while
executing the workflow
for this activity we don't need to
provide any specified message
secondly we have terminate workflow now
this is a mechanism
where we can ask the robot to terminate
rest activities
this activity is mostly used when there
is no data to process
to use this activity we may need to
provide the exception message
which the bot may login the error rock
file
which we can refer to later
third is throw through activity is a
mechanism
wherein if a bot fails to execute a
mentioned activity
it throws an error with a specified
error message to help us understand
better
lastly we have try catch now this
activity has three parts
the try block would be executed and if
there was an error it will be caught in
the catch section
now after executing the try block robot
will execute the finally block in any
condition
moving on what are breakpoints in uipath
breakpoints are used to purposely pause
the debugging process
on any activity that may trigger
execution issues
you can place and modify a breakpoint on
any of the activities as follows
so from the context menu you can right
click on an activity and select toggle
breakpoint
so let me show you how that works so
here in my sequence
i can just right click on it and here
you can see the toggle breakpoint option
you can go ahead and click on that
that is one of the methods or i can
select the activity and click on
the breakpoints button on the debug tab
so let me show you
here let me select this and in my debug
tab
i can click on breakpoints and say
toggle breakpoint
that is another method and lastly i can
press f9 while the desired activity is
being selected
it's as simple as that moving on to the
next question
what is a macro recorder a macro
recorder allows you to record mouse
events and keyboard activities to
generate automation scripts
now the activities are arranged based on
the sequence of actions being performed
on the screen
right so this sequence is saved in your
workflow which you can later use it to
play
back the recorded action moving on
what are the user events in uipath
mention a few
now user events in uipath specify the
actions performed due to the occurrence
of certain events
right some of these events could be
click key press
or monitor mouse or any monitor keyboard
etc
so when it comes to on click element now
this basically monitors
all the click events on a specified ui
element the mouse buttons left right and
middle are used for the click action
by default the left mouse button is
selected
on prepress element now this monitors
keyboard events on a specified ui
element special keys are supported and
you can select them from the activity
drop down list
this field supports only strings and
string variables
on click image this monitors the image
defined by the target ui element for
mouse input
and monitor mouse this monitors a
specified mouse key combination
system-wide event
moving on we have what are the different
activities performed by uipath
we have core activities for automation
processes
cognitive activities for language
translations credential activities for
enabling the addition or deletion of
credentials
database activities basically used for
executed queries transactions etc we
have excel activities for automating ms
excel tasks
ftp activities for performing functions
on the ftp server
intelligent ocr activities for
digitization and scraping
we have mail activities for working with
imap pop3
smtp outlook we have pdf activities for
data extraction from pdf
python activities for invoking python
scripts and methods
terminal activities for retrieving data
from the terminal
we have web activities for performing
soap and http
requests to any web apis and their word
activities for automating
activities in ms world so these are the
few you could mention
moving on what does the control room in
automation anywhere do
the control room is a web-based platform
that controls automation anywhere
all right the control room deals with
user management
source control i mean the code for the
bots is managed by the control room
dashboard it gives complete analytics
and results of automation anywhere bots
and license management the purchased
licenses for automation anywhere
configured in the control room now there
are two types of licenses in automation
anywhere you have the device license
which allows you to create a bot edit
bot and then run a bot
and you have the run license where the
user can only run the bot and cannot
make any changes
so this is what the control room does
moving on to the next question what is a
bot runner
now a bot runner is the machine where
you run the bot
now you could have multiple bots running
in parallel you only need the run
license to run the bots
the boss report back the execution logs
pass
fail status back to the control room
moving on what are task bots meta bots
and iq boards
so task bots basically are the bots that
automate a rule-based
repetitive task in areas like
documentation
administration hr claims management etc
moving on to meta bots these bots are
the automation building blocks
it is designed in such a way that with
application changes or updates
you need to make minimal edits to this
board any changes made to the
bot is easily reflected lastly we have
the iqbots
now this is an advanced tool it can
learn on its own and perform a task
according to it
iq bots offer automation using highly
advanced cognitive technology
moving on is robotic process automation
similar to screens keeping or macros
now screen scraping mostly talks about
the old green screen applications
mainframe ones where you basically
capture the screen
you process it based on its content and
information that you have
when it comes to rpa it is more
intelligent
more capable and much more robust what
it does it connects to the elements
whether they have windows applications
or java applications does not matter
they connect all the elements it does
use screen scraping yes
but it's just a part of robotic process
automation they're not entirely the same
moving on what are thick and thin
clients
a thick client is the application that
requires certain attribute features
using rpa tools
example a computer a calculator or
internet explorer
while a thin client is the application
that never requires the specific
properties while using the rpe tools
very simple the next question
is how is a chatbot different from rpa
now a chatbot is basically a bot that is
programmed
to chat with the user like a human being
would
right while in case of rta it is a bot
that is programmed to automate a manual
business process
of executing a task or any activity with
a business function
all right so a chatbot can be used as a
medium to feed input to the rpa bot
but it cannot replicate the features of
an rpa system
moving on to the final question can
selenium be used for rpa
well there are lots of test automation
tools in the market today
like selenium qdp and apm these are good
test automation tools
and no they cannot be used for robotic
process automation
test automation tools have a constraint
they require software in order to run
but in case of rpa it can be applied to
anything other than a product
and mostly rpa is used to automate
business processes
so selenium or any test automation tool
for that matter cannot be used for rpa
so with that we come to the end of this
crash course
i hope it helped you we'll be back with
more videos soon
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here